اليوم حتى من ربما كان لديه نوعا من الامل
للبقاء في هذه المدينه في خيام لاحظنا
صباحا ونحن ندخل
المدينه العديد من
الناجين يغادرون المدينه سيارات هناك من
قابلناهم في احدى المحطات محطات النقل
البري يبحثون عن سبل لمغادره المنطقه
نهائيا سالنا بعضهم الى اين تذهبون هناك
من لا يعرف حتى الى اين يذهب هناك من فقد
اهله هنا وهو الناجي الوحيد هناك من
برفقته اطفال عوائل يبحثون عن اماكن اكثر
امانا يتوقعون حتى سكان المخيمات عبد
القادر لم يعد يشعرون بالامان بعد بعد
الهزتين الاخيرتين صحيح
نعم هذا الذي لاحظناه وهناك بعض المخيمات
الصغيره التي نصبت حتى وسط هاتاي قبل قليل
بالقرب من مقر محافظه ولايه هاتاي كنا
هناك لكن هناك يعني تجديد امني كبير يمنع
التصوير هناك لاحظنا بان الناس من هم داخل
الخيام ليسوا براحه تامه هناك خوف شديد
هناك تطويق لهذه الخيام وعدم السماح لهم
بالخروج والتجول ربما او يعني يتم السماح
لهم فقط في رواق ضيق للحصول على الاكل على
المساعدات التي تقدم لهم بين الفينه
والاخرى